[Applause]
[Music]
before we get started let's just pay the
bills right now
[Music]
Main Street boxing gym this is all the
main street fighters come from 100% as
you can see there's a lot of bags full
size ring for your lipstick training a
lot of champions came in and out of this
place come here and train young and old
every bag imaginable
speed bag heavy bag full body bag full
size ring compact Oh with the key Oh
what did I tell you what did I tell you
there who did that to be did there I
told you his takedown game was insane
right I told you that kind of striking
if he's off a millisecond what was gonna
happen that I expect the khabib to beat
O'Connor in the striking game no then
but he did show the weakness in chin he
didn't allow Conner to touch that chin
up like I said you know Connors hope to
beating him was to outdance him knock
that chin but khabib is such a great
takedown artist that literally seconds
into the round the round one he at
Conner begins the game boy he faltered
kind of look like a deer being mauled by
lions
Connor looked scared when I told you
this before
fear allows people to act irrational or
fear a loud Khan attack irrational now
we can go into what happened after what
I tell you when you disrespect a man who
has pride in who takes his craft
respects his family loves his country
and you disrespect all those three
things what happens is there's a
cascading effect that that man can take
but so much and when you're at your
boiling point stuff boils over
what you saw was khabib at his boiling
point I do not condone outside of the
Ring action I do not condone him jumping
over the top of the Ring and kicking
whoever and fighting whoever I do not
condone these things but what I do say
as I understand them I understand a
measure of a man so this man decided at
that point in time those actions needed
to be done he didn't lash out at fans in
the crowd he lashed out pointedly at an
individual that was antagonizing him for
long parts and durations of time Conor
McGregor is not absolved of what he did
as well
he threw punches as well the things that
he did inside of the ring to people that
weren't part of the combat allowed him
to be attacked in a manner that he was
attacked so he is not absolved of any
guilt in this matter we had an
unfortunate incident after the fight
where behavior
not dictate what should have transpired
you understand these things that
transpired was unfortunate and it
actually marred a great victory and
could be khabib did his job
Kabhi Kabhi did his thing Connor as I
said he got fat is he as hungry as could
be no he's a great entertainer I don't
want to see him fight anymore
he will go down the road of Ronda Rousey
do other things don't go back in that
ring because it's not your sport anymore
now what will happen to khabib after
this we don't know well for the night he
is king and yeah he made a bed full of
thorns that he has to lay on but I think
khabib is comfortable in that cuz
revenge his best served cold and boy is
it sweet when he shed a loudmouth father
this is combat talk with the king boy if
you didn't see that fight you make sure
that you get yourself there to see it
[Applause]
[Music]